hello everyone hurts the radio show well
we are outside the studio we were just
pumped we had an incredible interview
with mr. john sayles and we had the
wonderful tadka tell our friend and
actor sitting in studio with us and the
time got away from us we didn't get a
chance to say thank you so we just
wanted to thank you for your time I
thought it was a pleasure cuz I thank
you and David was really it was it was
remarkable to get to share some ideas
and just hear all of John Sayles as
insights I was I was blown away it felt
like Christmas morning yeah they were
they were brilliant and we had a lot of
questions we want to ask and I'm just
curious were there other things that you
yellin touch on let me nothing nothing
just there were just things you know
just one thing I was just amazed so you
know by the process I was really
impressed first of all with how you and
David were so thoroughly prepared I mean
you had you know what was that about 10
or 12 pages of questions already written
up and then yet within that structure
that you obviously create for yourself
on a weekly basis you know there was a
there was a wonderful spontaneity to it
as well and just being able to sort of
simultaneously juggle what what you have
planned and then of course being in the
moment not only listening to what John
is saying extensively and then year guys
brilliant constant back and forth with
the the silent hand signals I felt like
it was like genitori and whatever the
first if prime is here you know the
first base coach was but anyway it was
that was it was cool to watch but yeah
there were just some interesting things
that came up and there was also a light
love there's that there was a lightness
to it as well and then once we sort of
got a little triangle communication go
I'm trying to stay out of your your way
as much as possible but I found myself
once we got going I found myself just so
sort of in it that I oh I forgot that we
were doing a radio show and then of
course we ended up running over i think
by virtue of that when i asked
question and I'm not quite as familiar
with all your silence single so I think
you know when John started to to
continue to answer that question I'd ask
them about the audition process and why
he chooses particular actors of course
we ran a few minutes over but yeah it
just it just felt like we were having a
conversation with somebody on the phone
and it could have gone on for hours I
was particularly interested there was a
question that you had asked about sort
of that balancing being as a creative
person or an artist balancing that sort
of need for one's privacy and space and
the sanctity of being able to have the
solitude to create and and then that
understandable natural resistance to
wanting to go out and and be the you
know door-to-door salesman of literally
yourself you know be as an actor or
filmmaker producer what heavy where you
have to kind of play that that deal will
that doctor dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
thing which I wrestled with myself and I
thought was interesting how John
answered the question by saying that
will just make sure you pick a role that
you can play and I thought that was kind
of a brilliant insight and you know
obviously like you essentially and then
he and then he also made the analogy or
i should say analogy was actually just a
literal example of Salvador Dali I guess
he had written a screenplay about him it
may or may not be produced but he
mentioned the whole character that
Salvador Dali created for himself his
sort of outside persona and then was
still going back and painting for 8-10
hours a day doing his thing and I was
curious to know of John what his
character is and if in fact perhaps we
were talking to his character today
because we don't know what he's like
when we don't see him in an interview we
don't know when he's you know he hangs
up the phone and he's there with you
know whomever is whoever he's spending
time with
eh whatever but you know mimic to some
extent he has to sort of put on that
mask as well to sell his films and
obviously the writing process for him
particularly for his own films is a
deeply personal one and yeah I mean I
could have picked that guy's brain for
four hours but it but it is an
interesting concept that that there is
sort of always a certain the fact that
he had been an actor and then I think
even again with the other insightful
question that you would ask them about
why he chose to do sort of blue-collar
work after you know getting a degree in
psychology from Williams and some of it
of course was pragmatically he was
relatively self-effacing and humble
about it that saying that he couldn't
get a job that I'm sure he could have
you know perhaps gone to New York and
done something a little bit more
conventional and secure be on Wall
Street or what-have-you just by virtue
of the degree whether he was trained and
fine answer or not I'm sure he could
have been able die it's almost as if
perhaps that amelia is a bit of his the
character that he plays uh you know I
mean that's just tadka tell speculation
I don't know I just think the guys have
really filmmaker and he's a huge
inspiration and it's a I was privileged
to be here today I really appreciate you
and David having me here big what and
yeah I mean I insist I wish the show's
two hours because we I'm sure all of us
were feeling we could still be in there
and gleaning whatever insights and
brilliance he had to share with us and
also sort of you know the more immersed
in it you are the sort of a less of the
the you know the inhibition to to to to
ask what's truly on your mind it impedes
you from sort of having that organic
conversation it's funny because when we
first were speaking with him before we
started the interview it was it felt so
you know relax the natural man of course
once the show began within you hear the
whole thing that is filmed gerd
you know la talk radio Karen Warren you
know kind of immediately you're where
we're in now that structures okay this
is show business and this is a you know
you're awesome yeah yeah and it you know
I felt that energy to myself and even
you know me do you guys have been
gracious enough to incorporate the
questions that I had written and sent to
david and when they were there and
something I found myself reading kind of
my own question and I was like I felt
like I was I was nerve that was when I
was most nervous reading him i have a
question i might wanna nervous i wrote
you know me but but it because I wanted
it was like it just a spontaneous thong
and you're trying to regurgitate your
own words as if they're natural but then
I don't know but I had a great time and
yeah